david investiga si los residentes de su
ciudad apoyan la construcción de una
nueva escuela tiene curiosidad acerca de
la diferencia de opinión entre los
residentes del norte y del sur de su
ciudad el obtuvo muestras aleatorias
separadas de votantes de cada región
a continuación se muestran los
resultados vemos que en el norte si
apoyan la construcción 54 personas de
120 y 66 personas no la apoyan y en el
sur apoya la construcción 77 personas de
140 y 63 no la apoyan david quiere usar
estos resultados para construir un
intervalo de confianza del 90% para
estimar la diferencia en la proporción
de los residentes de estas regiones que
apoyan la construcción del proyecto de
sub índice s&p subíndice n supón que
satisfacen todas las condiciones para la
inferencia cuál de las siguientes
opciones es un intervalo de confianza
correcto del 90% con base en las
muestras de david pausa en el vídeo y
traten de resolver esto por su cuenta
van a necesitar una calculadora y
dependiendo de su calculadora quizá
también necesiten una tabla z para
encontrar la solución en un
vídeo anterior presentamos la idea de
intervalos z de dos muestras y hablamos
de las condiciones para la inferencia
afortunadamente en este problema nos
dicen que se satisfacen las condiciones
para la inferencia por lo que podemos ir
directamente al cálculo del intervalo de
confianza dicho intervalo de confianza
va a ser la diferencia entre las
proporciones muestral es la proporción
muestral del sur de sombrero subíndice s
menos la proporción muestral del norte
más o menos el valor crítico z estrella
multiplicado por la estimación de la
desviación estándar de la distribución
muestral de la diferencia entre las
proporciones muestrales nuestra
estimación es la raíz cuadrada de peso
hombre subíndice s por 1 - p sombrero
subíndice s dividido entre el tamaño de
la muestra del sur más peso hombre
subíndice n por 1 menos de sombrero
subíndice n dividido entre el tamaño de
la muestra del norte
de la tabla vemos que en el sur tenemos
77 de 140 que apoyan la construcción así
que la proporción muestral del sur de
sombrero subíndice s es 77 entre 140 en
el norte peso hombre subíndice m será 54
de 120 cuál es el valor z crítico para
encontrar lo vamos a necesitar una
calculadora o una tabla zeta recordemos
que nos piden un intervalo de confianza
del 90% vamos a dibujarlo por aquí
esta es una distribución normal y
queremos un intervalo de confianza del
90% lo que significa que contiene el 90
por ciento de la distribución esto
significa que cada una de estas colas
que combinadas representan el 10 por
ciento de la distribución por separado
representan el 5% de la distribución
vamos a consultar la tabla zeta que nos
diga cuántas desviaciones estándar por
debajo de la media
debemos estar para tener 5 % aquí y eso
nos dirá si nos encontramos ahí por
arriba o por abajo ese será el valor
crítico
estrella veamos la tabla z para
encontrar esto nos interesa encontrar el
5% y quizá les parezca que estoy
haciendo lo opuesto a lo que nos piden
en el problema pero ya verán que no es
así estamos buscando el 5% y por acá
tenemos un poco más del 5% nos vamos
acercando poco a poco al 5% y ahora
encontramos un valor ligeramente por
debajo del 5% así que lo que nos
interesa se encuentra entre esta columna
y esta otra columna incluso podríamos
dividir la diferencia y decir que el
valor z sería más o menos 1.645 así que
esta seta estrella es aproximadamente
igual a 1.645 ya tenemos casi todos los
valores que necesitamos a excepción del
tamaño de la muestra en el sur en el
subíndice s que en la tabla vemos es
igual a 140 y en el subíndice n cuyo
valor es 120 ahora si lo único que
tenemos que hacer es escribir todo esto
en la calculadora lo cual va a ser algo
tardado pero qué
juntos aquí tenemos un emulador de la
calculadora texas instruments 84 y para
que el vídeo no sea tan extenso vamos a
aumentar la velocidad con la que
escribimos esto en la calculadora
primero vamos a calcular el límite
superior y después el límite inferior
aquí obtenemos el valor del límite
superior que es aproximadamente igual a
cero punto 202 con este valor
inmediatamente podemos ver las opciones
de respuesta que tengan este valor como
límite superior y en la opción se luce
muy bien ahora calculemos el límite
inferior usamos de nuevo la calculadora
y en lugar de volver a escribir todo
esto cambiamos un signo menos aquí pulsó
la tecla segunda y luego entrada y me
muestra lo que escribí y como solo
quiero modificar el signo + por el signo
menos muevo el cursor hasta ese lugar y
hago el cambio justo antes del radical
hacemos clic en enter y ahí está nuestro
límite inferior es aproximadamente igual
a menos 0.002 vemos la opción se y
coincide con el valor que tenemos aquí
con eso escogemos nuestra opción de
respuesta y con esto terminamos y nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo